Greetings student
doctors, my
name is Dr.
Bradley Hickey.
I am an assistant
professor of clinical
medicine here at
the Arkansas campus.
It is my pleasure
to introduce you to
this foundational
lecture in immunology.
The title of
today's lecture is
Immunogenetics, Lymphocyte
Activation, Immune
Regulation, and
Tolerance, Part 1.
This lecture emphasizes
rules and logic over
memorization. If
you understand the
constraints the immune
system operates under,
the details that come
later will make sense.
You'll also notice this
lecture is relatively
graphic light. That
is intentional.
The goal today is to
build a conceptual
scaffolding
first. Once you
understand the
rules of the system,
the diagrams in
later lectures
become much easier
to interpret.
Our lecture orientation,
why these rules matter.
We are beginning a
lecture that establishes
non-negotiable rules
for how adaptive
immunity operates.
These are not details
that can be memorized
and forgotten.
They determine what
the immune system is
capable of seeing, and
just as importantly,
what it is incapable
of responding to.
As we move through
this lecture, keep
returning to one
question. What problem
is the immune system
trying to solve at
this step. When you
can name the problem,
the mechanism
usually makes sense.
When you cannot name
the problem, the
mechanism feels like
arbitrary memorization.
Today's content
provides the framework
that will support later
discussions of
infection, autoimmunity,
transplantation, and
immune deficiency.
If this foundation
is solid, everything
downstream becomes
easier to reason through
because you can predict
what the immune system
will do learning
objectives and conceptual
focus the goal of
today's session is
understanding not memorization
you're not expected
to recite long lists
of molecules you are
expected to understand
why certain constraints
exist in adaptive
immunity by the end of
the lecture you should
be able to explain
why T cells require
antigen presentation why
MHC molecules are
essential and how these
requirements reduce the
risk of inappropriate
immune activation
while still enabling
rapid defense think
of these objectives as
anchors later in the
course when you learn new
cell types cytokines
and clinical syndromes
you should be able
to connect them back
to these anchors the
unique role of t-cells
surveillance of intracellular
problems t-cells
are specialized for
detecting threats that
originate inside
cells most importantly
viral infection and
malignant transformation
that is a fundamentally
different task from
what antibodies do
because antibodies operate
outside of cells so
the immune system
faces a problem how
can it detect what is
happening inside a cell
without opening the
cell up or destroying
tissue indiscriminately
the solution is to have
cells report fragments
of their internal
proteins to the cell
surface in a controlled
format T cells then
function less like
antigen binders and more
like inspectors they
scan reported peptides
and decide whether what
the cell is producing
is consistent with
health or or rather
if it suggests infection
or transformation.
This is the reason T
-cells are so powerful,
and also why they
require strong
regulation. An overly
trigger-happy T-cell
system would be
catastrophic because it
would turn normal
tissues into targets.
Why T-cells do not
bind free antigen,
safety, and context.
Next, unlike B cells,
T cells do not bind
intact antigen.
This is not a
design flaw. It's
a safety feature
that forces context
into the decision
to activate.
If T cells could bind
free antigen directly,
the immune system
would risk activating
T cells based on
harmless exposures,
such as food antigens,
commensal microbes,
or debris from
normal cell turnover.
In other words, it would
confuse exposure
with danger.
Requiring antigen
processing
inserts a checkpoint.
Another cell must
capture antigen, process
it, and present it.
That presenting cell
can also provide
additional signals that
effectively say, this
is worth responding to.
This also helps you
understand
tolerance later.
A major goal of
tolerance mechanisms is
to prevent T cells
from treating ordinary
self-peptides as if
they were threats.
Moving on, the major
histocompatibility
complex and HLA, the
display platform.
The molecules
responsible for antigen
presentation are
encoded in the major
histocompatibility
complex, or MHC.
In humans, we call
these gene products
HLA molecules, human
leukocyte antigens.
Rather than acting
like receptors,
MHC molecules act like
display platforms.
They hold peptides in a
way that allows T-cells
to inspect them with
the T-cell receptor.
A useful way
to think about
MHC is as the
immune system's
standardized
reporting format.
Cells cannot
simply tell T-cells
what they contain.
They can only show
peptides using
the MHC complex.
This is why the
MHC is so central.
If you change the
display platform,
you change which
peptides can be
shown and which T
-cells can respond.
MHC polymorphism. Why are
there so many alleles?
The MHC locus is
one of the most
polymorphic regions
of the human genome.
That means there
are many alleles, or
rather many
naturally occurring
versions, of MHC genes
in the population.
Why would evolution
favor this? because
pathogens evolve.
If all humans
presented peptides
the same way, a
pathogen that escapes
presentation in
one person could
escape in everyone.
MHC diversity solves
that population level
problem. A pathogen
that evades one person's
MHC presentation may
still be effectively
presented in another
person. So polymorphism
is a survival strategy
for the species.
There is a trade-off.
At the individual level,
your specific MHC
alleles determine which
peptides you present
efficiently and which
you present poorly.
That contributes to
differences in
susceptibility, disease
severity, and variability
in vaccine responses.
Consequences of
MHC diversity.
Individual variation
and transplantation.
Because individuals
differ in their MHC
molecules, they differ
in which peptides
they can present. That
means immune responses
to the same pathogen
can look meaningfully
different from one
person to another.
This is one reason
two patients
can have very
different clinical
courses with the
same infection.
They may not be
presenting the same key
protective peptides to
their T cells with the
same efficiency. This
diversity becomes a
major clinical problem
in transplantation. When
tissues move from one
person to another,
the recipient's immune
system may see the
donor's MHC molecules
themselves as foreign.
In other words,
the immune system
can treat
unfamiliar display
platforms as
evidence of non-self.
That is why matching
HLA matters so
much. You are trying
to minimize how
foreign the donor's
antigen presentation
machinery appears
to the recipient.
MHC restriction what
a t-cell actually
recognizes the t-cell
receptor recognizes antigen
only when it is bound
to an MHC molecule
this requirement is
called MHC restriction
and it is essential
for understanding t
-cell specificity a t
-cell is not specific for
a peptide alone it is
specific for a peptide
presented by a
particular MHC molecule.
That is why the
same peptide
presented on a
different MHC allele
may not activate
the same T-cell.
This also explains why T
-cells are so
personalized.
Your T-cells
are educated in
your thymus to
operate in the
context of your
own MHC molecules.
The practical takeaway
here is that T-cell
recognition is always
a two-part check. There
is peptide identity
plus the MHC context.
Keeping that in
mind will make later
discussions of
tolerance and transplant
rejection much
easier to understand.
Why there are
two MHC classes,
two sources of antigen
and two responses.
The immune system uses
two antigen presentation
pathways because
antigens originate
from two fundamentally
different sources.
Some threats arise
inside cells, like viral
replication or abnormal
protein production.
Other threats
originate outside the
cell, like bacteria
in tissues or proteins
in the extracellular
environment.
A single presentation
system would be a
compromise and would
blur these categories.
Instead, the
immune system
evolved two
specialized pathways
that preserved
the distinction.
MHC class 1 is
for intracellular
peptides, and MHC class 2
is for extracellular
peptides.
This matters because the
appropriate immune
response differs.
Intracellular threats
often require killing
infected cells,
whereas extracellular
threats often require
coordination and activation
of phagocytes and
antibody production.
MHC class 1 overview.
you continuous
intracellular monitoring
MHC class 1 molecules
present peptides derived
from intracellular
proteins importantly
this is not only during
infection cells are
constantly constantly
processing their own
proteins as part of
normal turnover every
nucleated cell expresses
MHC class 1 which
means every nucleated
cell is constantly
reporting a sample of
its internal protein
environment. That is
the basic mechanism of
immune surveillance.
CD8 T-cells use
these class 1 peptide
displays to detect
abnormal intracellular
activity. If the
peptides suggest
infection or
transformation, CD8 T-cells
can eliminate the
affected cell, limiting
spread and protecting
the organism.
Notice the logic
here. Class 1 is about
finding problems
early at the level
of single infected
or abnormal cells
before the problem
becomes systemic.
Generation of
peptides for MHC
Class I presentation
At this stage,
the focus shifts
to where peptides
for Class I
actually come from.
Importantly, the
immune system does
not create a
special degradation
pathway solely for
immune surveillance.
Instead, it
relies on routine
cellular housekeeping.
Cells are constantly
synthesizing and
degrading proteins
as part of normal
regulation, quality
control, and adaptation.
When a virus
infects a cell,
viral proteins are
produced inside
the host cell
and are degraded
through the
same mechanisms.
This allows the immune
system to sample
intracellular activity
without distinguishing
self from non
-self at this step.
The key concept
is that antigen
presentation begins
as passive sampling,
not as an
inflammatory decision.
Proteosomal Processing
and Peptide Generation
Most intracellular
proteins are degraded
by the proteasome,
a large proteolytic
complex responsible
for protein turnover.
The proteasome
generates many peptide
fragments of varying
length and composition.
Only a subset of
these fragments will
be appropriate for
MHC class I binding.
At this stage, the
cell is not deciding
whether a peptide
is dangerous.
It is simply
generating molecular
fragments as part of
normal metabolism.
This reinforces the
idea that immune
surveillance is
layered onto normal
biology rather
than replacing it.
Transport of peptides
into the endoplasmic
reticulum. Peptides
generated in the cytosol
must be transported
into the endoplasmic
reticulum to bind MHC
class 1 molecules.
This transport is
mediated by TAP, the
transporter associated
with antigen processing.
TAP does not transport
peptides
indiscriminately.
It favors peptides
of appropriate
length and biochemical
properties.
This introduces
another quality
control checkpoint,
narrowing the pool
of peptides available
for presentation.
If TAP function
is impaired,
antigen
presentation fails
even if peptides
are abundant.
Assembly and
Stabilization of
the MHC Class I
Peptide Complex
Within the
endoplasmic reticulum,
newly synthesized
MHC Class I molecules
require peptide
binding for stability.
Empty MHC molecules
are unstable and
are retained or
degraded rather than
displayed. This
ensures that T-cells
never encounter
empty MHC scaffolds.
Only peptide-loaded
MHC molecules
are transported to
the cell surface.
This step tightly links
intracellular peptide
availability to surface
antigen display.
CD8 T-cells and Targeted
Cell Elimination
CD8-positive T
-cells specialize
in recognizing
peptides presented
by MHC class I molecules.
They interrogate
individual cells rather
than scanning the
extracellular environment.
When a CD8-t cell
encounters a peptide, MHC
complex, it assesses
whether the peptide
fits within the expected
self-repertoire.
If the peptide is
abnormal, the CD8
-t cell can initiate
targeted killing.
This response prioritizes
precision over
widespread inflammation.
Continuous
nature of class 1
presentation. It is
critical to understand
that MHC class
1 presentation
is continuous
and non-optional.
Cells cannot selectively
hide peptides
from immune surveillance.
This constant
reporting allows
the immune system to
detect changes early.
From a system's
perspective, this
minimizes the need
for large-scale
inflammatory responses.
Instead, problems
can be addressed
at the level of
individual cells.
Introducing the MHC
Class II Pathway.
Why a second presentation
pathway is needed.
Extracellular antigens
present a different
challenge for the
immune system. These
antigens must be
sampled from the
environment rather
than from within cells.
Responding to these
threats often requires
coordination rather
than cytotoxicity.
MHC class II molecules
exist to support
this coordinated
immune response.
Restriction of
MHC class II to
professional antigen
-presenting cells.
MHC class II
expression is limited
to professional
antigen presenting
cells. These
include dendritic
cells, macrophages,
and B cells.
This restriction
ensures that
extracellular
antigen presentation
occurs in a
regulated context.
These cells are
equipped to provide
both antigen
presentation and
additional
instructional signals.
Together, these
signals guide the
nature of the
immune response.
uptake and processing
of extracellular
antigens extracellular
antigens are internalized
through endocytosis
or phagocytosis once
internalized proteins
are degraded within
vesicular compartments
this compartmentalization
keeps extracellular
and intracellular
pathways separate it
also allows antigen
presenting cells to
regulate which antigens
are sampled once
again it also allows
antigen presenting
cells to regulate which
antigens are sampled
this control is essential
for maintaining
immune precision and
preventing inappropriate
activation invariant
chain preventing
********* peptide bonding
at the as the MHC class
2 pathway begins the
immune system faces
an immediate problem,
preventing inappropriate
peptide binding.
MHC class 2 molecules
are synthesized in
the endoplasmic reticulum,
the same location
where class 1 molecules
load peptides.
Without protection,
class 2 molecules could
bind intracellular
peptides, which
would collapse
the separation
between the pathways.
The invariant chain
solves this problem
by physically
occupying the peptide
binding groove of
class 2 molecules.
This blockade ensures
that class 2 molecules
remain empty of antigen
until they reach
the correct intracellular
compartment.
Targeting MHC class 2 to
endosomal compartments.
The invariant chain
does more than block
peptide binding. It
also contains signals
that direct MHC class
2 molecules towards
endosomal and
lysosomal compartments.
These compartments are
where extracellular
antigens are processed
into peptides. This
targeting function
preserves pathway
fidelity by ensuring class
II molecules encounter
only extracellular
derived peptides.
Without this targeting,
class II presentation
would lose its
specificity.
Controlled degradation
of the invariant
chain. Once MHC class
II molecules reach the
appropriate vesicular
compartments, the
invariant chain is not
removed all at once.
Instead, it is
gradually degraded
by proteases
within the vesicle.
This stepwise
degradation reflects
the immune
system's emphasis
on control rather
than speed.
By retaining partial
fragments of the
invariant chain during
transit, the cell
prevents accidental
peptide loading.
Only when the class
2 molecule is fully
positioned in the
correct compartment
does peptide loading
become possible.
CLIP as a temporary
placeholder.
The final fragment of
the invariant chain
that remains bound is
known as CLIP, class
2 associated invariant
chain peptide. CLIP
occupies the peptide
binding groove and
prevents ********* or
low affinity peptide
binding. At this
stage, the class 2
molecule is properly
localized but still
protected this represents
another checkpoint
that prioritizes accuracy
over rapid presentation
the immune system
consistently favors
controlled presentation
rather than
maximal speed HLA DM
and peptide editing HLA
DM stands for human
leukocyte antigen DM,
where DM refers
to a region
and a locus on
the HMC complex.
This HLA-DM plays
a critical role in
removing clip and
facilitating peptide exchange.
Rather than simply
displacing clip,
HLA-DM promotes
the binding of
peptides that form stable
complexes with
class II molecules.
This editing function
ensures that peptides
displayed on the cell
surface persist long
enough to be recognized
by CD4 T cells.
Weakly bound peptides
are less likely to
survive this editing
process. As a result,
the immune system
increases the signal
-to-noise ratio of
antigen presentation.
Surface expression of MHC
class 2 peptide
complexes.
After successful
peptide loading, MHC
class 2 peptide
complexes are transported
to the cell surface.
These complexes
are displayed only on
professional antigen
presenting cells.
This restriction
ensures that CD4 T
cell activation occurs
in an appropriate
immunologic context.
At the surface, these
complexes function as
instructional signals
rather than direct
triggers of cytotoxicity.
This distinction
underlies the coordinating
role of CD4 T cells.
CD4 T-cells as Directors
of Immune Responses
CD4 T-cells do
not directly
eliminate infected cells.
Instead, they act as
directors, influencing
the behavior of
other immune cells.
Through cytokine
production and cell-to-cell
interactions, CD4 T
-cells shape macrophage
activation, antibody
production, and the
development of cytotoxic
responses. Because
of this central role,
improper CD4 T-cell
activation can have
widespread consequences.
This explains why
CD4 dysfunction is
associated with profound
immune impairment.
Why coordination
is essential.
An immune
response without
coordination would
be inefficient
and potentially
destructive.
CD4 T-cells help
determine not only
whether a response
occurs, but
also what type of
response develops.
They influence magnitude,
duration, and
effector mechanisms.
This layered
regulation reduces
unnecessary
tissue damage.
It also allows the
immune system to adapt
responses to different
classes of pathogens.
Revisiting the
division between Class
I and Class II
At this point, it
is useful to
explicitly contrast the
two antigen
presentation pathways.
Class 1 presentation
surveys intracellular
activity and
engages CD8 T-cells.
Class 2 presentation
samples extracellular
material and
engages CD4 T-cells.
This division allows
the immune system
to deploy distinct
effector strategies.
Maintaining the
separation is essential
for immune precision.
The antigen
presentation mechanisms
discussed so far forms
the foundation for
T-cell activation.
Downstream topics such
as co-stimulation,
tolerance, and effector
differentiation
all depend on
these early steps.
Errors in antigen
presentation can
profoundly alter
immune outcomes.
Keeping these
principles in mind
will help integrate
future lectures.
antigen presentation
is necessary but not
sufficient up to this
point we have focused on
how antigens are
processed and displayed
to t-cells however it is
essential to understand
that correct antigen
presentation alone
does not automatically
lead to t-cell activation
if antigen presentation
were sufficient
by itself the immune
system would constantly
activate in response
to harmless self
peptides environmental
antigens and debris from
normal cell turnover
to prevent this the
immune system separates
the act of recognition
from the decision to
respond this separation
allows T cells together
information before
committing to activation
this concept will
repeatedly appear
throughout immunology
especially when discussing
tolerance and auto
Co-stimulation, the
second signal. Co
-stimulation refers to
additional molecular
interactions that must
occur alongside antigen
recognition for full
T cell activation.
These signals provide
contextual information
that helps the T cell
determine whether
the antigen is
associated with danger.
In the absence of co
-stimulation, antigen
recognition alone
is interpreted as
insufficient justification
for activation.
This two-signal
requirement acts as a
critical safeguard,
preventing immune
responses against
innocuous antigens.
Understanding this
principle helps explain
why immune responses
are tightly controlled
despite constant
antigen exposure.
Why only professional
APCs activate naive
T-cells. Not all
cells that present
antigen are capable
of activating T cells.
Professional
antigen presenting
cells possess
specialized machinery
that allows them
to deliver both
antigen and co
-stimulatory signals.
This specialization
ensures that immune
activation is centralized
and regulated rather
than occurring randomly
throughout tissues.
It also explains why
most tissue cells,
despite expressing MHC
class 1, do not activate
naive T-cells. This
distinction is essential
for maintaining
peripheral tolerance.
Consequences of antigen
recognition without
co-stimulation.
When a T-cell recognizes
antigen without
receiving co-stimulatory
signals, it does
not simply ignore the
encounter. Instead,
the T-cell may enter
a stage of long
-term unresponsiveness
known as energy.
Anergic T-cells
are functionally
impaired and unable
to respond even if
they later encounter
proper stimulation.
This mechanism serves
as an additional
safeguard against
autoimmunity.
Failures in this
process contribute to
inappropriate immune
activation and disease.
Contextual information
shapes immune responses.
Co-stimulatory signals
convey information
about the immunologic
context in which
antigen is encountered.
They help T-cells
distinguish between
infection, inflammation,
and normal
physiological processes.
This context determines
not only whether a
response occurs, but
also what type of
response develops.
Through this mechanism,
the immune system
adapts its behavior
to different
biological situations.
This flexibility is a
hallmark of
adaptive immunity.
Connecting co-stimulation
to tolerance mechanisms.
The requirement for co
-stimulation is closely
linked to mechanisms
of immune tolerance.
Central tolerance
removes many
self-reactive
T-cells during
development, but
it is not complete.
Peripheral tolerance
provides additional
layers of control and
mature immune responses.
Antigen presentation
in the absence
of co-stimulation
is one way
peripheral tolerance
is enforced.
Together, these
mechanisms
reduce the risk
of autoimmunity.
Tolerance as an active,
regulated process.
Tolerance is not
a passive failure
of the immune system
to respond. It
is an active,
regulated process that
requires continuous
enforcement.
Multiple checkpoints,
including co
-stimulation
requirements, work
together to maintain
self-tolerance.
Disruption of
these checkpoints
can have severe
consequences.
This concept helps
explain why autoimmune
diseases are often
multifactorial.
Balancing immune
responsiveness
with self-protection.
The immune system
must strike a balance
between responsiveness
and restraint.
Responding too
aggressively risks tissue
damage, while
insufficient responses
allow infection or
malignancy to progress.
Antigen presentation,
co-stimulation,
and tolerance mechanisms
collectively maintain
this balance.
Even small
disruptions can tip
the system
towards pathology.
Understanding this
balance is central to
understanding immune
-mediated disease.
Clinical relevance of
co-stimulatory pathways.
Co-stimulatory
pathways are important
targets for clinical
intervention.
Therapeutic manipulation
of these pathways
can enhance or suppress
immune responses.
Such strategies
are used in
transplantation,
autoimmune disease,
and cancer immunotherapy.
Although the molecular
details will be covered
later, the conceptual
framework begins
here. This illustrates
how basic immunologic
principles translate
into clinical practice.
Integrating antigen
presentation,
co-stimulation,
and tolerance.
Antigen presentation
provides
specificity,
identifying what the
immune system is
responding to.
Co-stimulation
provides context,
determining whether a
response should occur.
Tolerance mechanisms
provide restraint,
preventing harmful
cell-free activity.
Together, these
processes govern
adaptive immune
decision-making.
This integrated
framework sets the
stage for
understanding effector
function and
immune regulation.
Super antigens,
an exception
to normal antigen
recognition.
Up to this point, we have
emphasized how
tightly regulated
antigen recognition
normally is.
Super antigens
represent a
major exception
to these rules.
They bypass normal
peptide specificity
by binding simultaneously
to MHC class
II molecules and
the T cell receptor
outside the peptide
binding groove. This
abnormal binding forces
T-cell activation
without proper
antigen specificity.
The result is widespread,
inappropriate
immune activation.
Mechanisms of
superantigen
-induced activation
Superantigens
do not require
intracellular processing.
They bind intact to
the outside of MHC
class II molecules
and cross-link
them to T-cell receptors.
This interaction
activates large
numbers of T-cells
regardless of
antigen specificity.
Normal checkpoints
are bypassed and
the immune response
becomes uncontrolled.
This explains
the severity of
diseases associated
with superantigens.
Consequences of widespread
T-cell activation
When many T-cells are
activated simultaneously,
massive cytokine
release can occur.
This phenomenon is often
referred to as a
cytokine storm.
The resulting
inflammation can
lead to fever,
hypotension, and
ultimately organ
dysfunction.
These outcomes
illustrate the danger of
bypassing normal immune
regulatory mechanisms.
Superantigens
demonstrate why
immune precision
is essential.
Clinical example of
superantigen exposure.
several bacterial toxins
act as super antigens
one example is that
found in toxic shock
syndrome these toxins
are associated with
severe clinical syndromes
understanding this
mechanism helps explain
the rapid onset and
severity of these
conditions this reinforces
the importance of
controlled antigen
recognition MHC expression
patterns and immune
outcomes the The
distribution of MHC molecules
influences how immune
responses unfold.
Because MHC class
1 is expressed
on all nucleated cells,
intracellular surveillance
is widespread.
In contrast,
MHC class 2 expression
is restricted to
professional antigen
presenting cells.
These expression
patterns shape
where and how
immune activation
occurs. This
organization contributes
to immune efficiency
and safety.
Genetic variation in MHC
and disease
susceptibility.
Differences
in MHC alleles
influence disease
susceptibility.
Certain MHC variants
are associated with
increased risk for
specific diseases.
These associations
reflect differences
in peptide presentation
rather than
direct pathogenic
effects. Understanding
this helps explain
why genetics
influences immune
-mediated disease.
This concept
bridges basic
immunology and
clinical observation.
Antigen presentation
in transplantation.
plays a central
role in transplant
rejection.
Recipient T-cells
may recognize
donor MHC molecules
as foreign.
This recognition
can occur even
in the absence of
donor peptides.
This phenomenon
highlights how
sensitive the
immune system is to
changes in antigen
presentation.
It also explains
why MHC matching
is critical in
transplantation.
In transplantation,
recipient T
-cells can recognize
donor antigens
through multiple
mechanisms.
Direct allorecognition
involves
recognition of intact
donor MHC molecules.
Indirect
allurecognition involves
processing of
donor proteins by
recipient antigen
-presenting cells.
Both of these mechanisms
contribute to
transplant rejection.
Integrating antigen
presentation
with immune regulation.
Antigen presentation
does not operate in
isolation. It interacts
with co-stimulation,
cytokine signaling, and
tolerance mechanisms.
Together,
these systems determine
immune outcomes.
Disruption at any level
can produce disease.
This integrated view is
essential for
clinical reasoning.
Key takeaways.
Antigen presentation
determines
what the immune
system can see.
MHC molecules
constrain and
guide T-cell recognition.
Co-stimulation and
tolerance provide both
context and restraint.
together these processes
ensure immune precision
these principles
together form the
foundation of adaptive
immunity transition to
subsequent topics in
immunology the material
in this lecture
establishes the mechanism
mechanistic foundation
for adaptive immune
responses subsequent
lectures will build on
these principles keeping
this framework in
mind will help you
integrate new information
antigen presentation
is not an isolated topic
but a recurring theme
in summation antigen
presentation determines
what the immune system
can see MHC molecules
constrain t-cell
recognition to specific
regulated context
this design prevents
indiscriminate or
dangerous immune activation
Co-stimulation and
tolerance mechanisms
determine whether
a response occurs
Separation of
recognition from action
protects the host
Failures in these
controls explain
autoimmunity,
transplant rejection,
and immune evasion
Listed at the bottom
of the slide is a
set of core references
if you need to seek
out additional
information on this topic
and in conclusion
i would like to say
it's been a pleasure
lecturing you today
attached to this
slide is the link to
feedback for the
faculty and i welcome
your feedback i would
love to make this
presentation better
for future generations
thank you for your
time and i look
forward to speaking
with you again soon